The ancient tradition of Xmas began in the
year 2801, when the Friendly Robot Company
developed a high-powered mechanical Santa
capable of delivering over five mega presents
per second.
Hey.
They tricked him out with a pair of carbon fiber tams and a chrome naughty-nice sensor.
So he'd know who deserved gifts and who
deserved brutal punishment.
Yo, that might have been the first mistake
right there.
But on Santa's very first delivery, something
went tragically mashugana.
His naughty-nice sensor malfunctioned.
Man, that's some bleeped up-
Yay! Santa is here!
Oh. Thank you.
I'm sorry, kids.
I never wanted you to know Santa was real.